thomas ligne de bonnes il est
journaliste et historien il s'exprime
depuis stockholm tomas une bonne merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors là ce fait nous disait se
distingue un par sa gestion de
l'épidémie avec des mesures prises sur
le long terme comme l'a indiqué le
premier ministre suédois
quelle première leçon pouvez vous tirer
de cette stratégie suédoise s'émeut
départager je pense d'abord que on voit
que le nombre de décès est quand même en
ses roues et c'est très inquiétant
en même temps on voit aussi que comme le
premier ministre dit il faut voir ça de
l'ong terme
qu'est ce qui va être le résultat dans
un an ça ces deux infections je voudrais
aussi dire une toise et réflexion c'est
que est-ce que ça a été possible en
suède de faim autrement que d'avoir à
cette politique cette stratégie qu'on a
fait parce que chaque pays n'est pas on
peut pas comparer le pays facilement il
ya des différences culturelles et
historiques entre chaque pays
qu'est ce qui fait justement que le
confinement n'aurait peut-être pas
fonctionné en suède selon vous je pense
d'abord comme je suis historien je pense
à l'histoire nous allons nous n'avons
pas les deux guerres dépit 1800 09
on n'a pas les grandes crises
catastrophe comme dans beaucoup d'autres
pays en europe dont un tollé dès que et
très renfermé qu'on finit comme dans
d'autres pays
ça serait très difficile les jambes ont
probablement pas accepter ça de la même
façon d'abord deuxièmement je pense
qu'il ya une côte et si on veut dire
d'abord pragmatique mais aussi
rationaliste scientifique en suède qui
est très fort dit si le gouvernement et
les responsables disent que l'on peut
avoir une politique qui réponde aux
demandes scientifique et ce qui est
scientifique comme prétendent être
scientifique les jambes pour accepter ça
et évidemment pour la troisième chose si
on est moins en forme et où les
autorités disent que c'est sait bien que
c'est ces scientifiques évidemment les
jambes elle tenir à cette politique est
du côté de la communauté médicale est ce
que ces mesures font sont bien
accueillis est ce que finalement les
hôpitaux ont tenu les hôpitaux ont fini
avec beaucoup de problèmes et tous les
médecins sont pas d'accord mais c'est
intéressant à voir comment un épices où
la population se rassemble derrière la
majorité ou d'ariel et les gouvernants
quand il ya une crise
donc quand les mills incertaine très
grand virologues ses dragons ont
critiqué la politique du gouvernement
la plupart des suédois ont dit que ça il
faut pas faire il faut il faut rester
derrière le gouvernement a surtout
derrière l'administration nationale de
la santé qui joue une rôle très
important dans en suède
finalement cette crise elle a aussi
montré un lien fort entre la population
et ses gouvernants j'ai pas entendu la
question
cette crise du coronavirus oms fed ce
que vous nous disiez c'est qu'elle a
montré finalement un véritable lien et
une confiance entre la population et ses
gouvernants je pense et je pense aussi
quand les suédois par les suédois en
général qui n'ont pas lire coronavirus
la plupart des gens ne sommes pas à 7,7
cette maladie quand il voit aussi
comment ça se passe dans d'autres pays
en europe quand et bois les rues vides à
paris et d'autres villes françaises et
bois tout le monde avec des masques ils
disent mais heureusement qu'on vit dans
un pays où on arrive à habib ressent
tout ça donc c'est une sont certains
fierté qu'on peut traiter qui en même
temps qui est un peu égocentrique et
nationalisme et ya quand même c'était
attitude qui comptent eux boivent en
suède en ce moment les gens sont la
plupart et derrière le gouvernement
absolument pour conclure on a vu dans la
gestion de la pide de l'épidémie par bon
la question des maisons de retraite où
on compte un tiers des victimes du coup
vite 19
est-ce que là au sujet des maisons de
retraite on peut parler d'une erreur de
stratégie
je pense hélas ils ont bien le chef
aussi de la l'administration nationale
il a admis aussi que l' on a pas on n'a
pas bien fait et c'est là est la
critique quand on demande un suédois
pourquoi il ya tellement de décès est
immonde qui vont pas dire que c'est
parce qu'on n'est pas renfermé et
confiné c'est parce que on n'a pas
réussi avec est la maison des retraites
c'est cela la réponse merci beaucoup
thomas une bonne d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et historien vous vous
exprimiez depuis stockholm